well that was Graham Stewart a little
bit earlier on well joining me now is
the labor party chair annalize Dodds uh
very good morning to you thanks so much
for talking to us here this morning so
the government is deciding not to tell
people to cut their energy use this
winter they essentially say it's up to
them what does labor think
well actually we know that huge numbers
of people have already cut their energy
use I mean extraordinarily complacent I
have to say to hear some of this
discussion when already so many people
have been forced to drastically cut back
on their use of energy you know many
families expecting that they will only
be heating one room looking forward to
winter so that's already the reality for
many families and frankly this is a
damning indictment of conservative
policy over the last 12 years you know
we've not seen ultimately that gas
storage being open in fact a lot of it
has been closed During the period of
conservative-led governments we've not
seen the investment in Energy Efficiency
we've now got some of the coldest and
draftiest homes in all of Europe in our
country Libra's been calling for a mass
home insulation program no action it
seems being taken in that direction and
I'm afraid it's just not true for the
conservative government to say that we
have the right Energy Mix now we've seen
enormous delays on nuclear we've seen
huge blockages on homegrown Renewables
now that's why labors said we will be
sprinting ahead instead and why we'd
have GB energy to provide that green
cheaper energy for the future so you
know really this is an indication of
government failure that we're even
having these discussions right now about
potential blackouts but I just wanted to
ask you again about this question of
telling people to cut their own energy I
mean they would say they did say that
there's information out there on
official websites that you can get tips
on how to to save energy if you want to
but they say as far as energy security
is concerned it really wouldn't make
much difference
well actually improving the Energy
Efficiency of our homes would make a big
difference but that's not what it seems
the government is focused on they should
be focused on improving insulation for
example that would enable the creation
of jobs up and down our country's labor
has set out exactly how we would deliver
that in fact we've been calling for it
for a month upon month upon month and
still no action in the green homes grant
for example which was meant to be
improving the Energy Efficiency and
usage in British homes is a complete
failure and nothing's been done to
improve that situation so I think we
need to see action in that area but I do
think that the British public when so
many are already scaling back radically
on their energy use when they've been
forced to do that because of the
conservatives cost of living crisis as
well as the rising cost of energy I
think that would come across frankly as
very patronizing to those people
so what would labor do to ensure
stability of energy Supply and the
reason we're talking about this is
National Grid has said in the absolute
worst case scenario there may be the
prospect of planned blackouts in the
country what would labor do to ensure
stability of energy Supply in the short
term this winter next winter what would
they do
well the first thing we would do is that
mass home insulation program kirstema
called for that many many months ago
that should be taking place right now if
we'd acted on home insulation then the
very few poorest households would not be
as worried as they are right now about
the prospect of a cold winter secondly
we would be acting right now to improve
our energy Supply you know again care
set out in his speech at this conference
those measures up to 2030 some of them
to be taken very very speedily indeed to
be doing things like increasing those
homegrown Renewables you know we know
how to do this as a country just
yesterday in fact I was visiting a
facility where there's a huge enormous
battery going directly into the National
Grid but it's one of just a small number
of pilot projects you know the time for
Pilots is beyond us we should be acting
now and again Libra set out those plans
to act now and this is not only
important for our energy supply for
preventing these potential challenges
when it comes to blackouts it's also
very important for making sure our
country has those jobs of the future in
those green technologies in the future
and I'm afraid in both of those areas
the conservatives have failed while
labor has that plan that green
Prosperity plan to take our country
forward
but it's expensive isn't it I mean
Labor's talking about being an energy
superpower by 2030. I mean 28 billion
pounds each year
on this plan to boost Renewables and
Energy Efficiency how is that going to
be paid for
well actually it's very important that
we do that and if we don't it's going to
be more expensive in the future in terms
of that 28 billion pounds pledge we made
that some time ago we made that pledge
because ultimately unless we act the
costs for the future for our country
will be astronomical you know the um Obi
the independent fiscal Watchdog it's
made clear that if we put off this
action for another 10 years you know
we've had 12 years of drift if we put
off this action around the drive to Net
Zero for another 10 years they've said
it's going to be twice as expensive for
our country but also those renewable
Technologies are far cheaper when it
comes to energy it's far lower cost for
consumers that's why we should have been
acting over the last last 12 years we
haven't been labor set out that very
clear plan for us to make sure that we
get the benefit of those green
technologies you know our country she
can be a world leader in them we can
make up those 12 lost years if we have
that plan ultimately but we do need to
be acting on Energy Efficiency too and
that's why Labor's been calling for that
mass Homer insulation that's so
important and frankly if we don't do
these things the costs will just get
more and more for families and for
government okay I just want to ask you
about mortgage rates as well because
this week we've seen the average
two-year fixed rate mortgage rise to
over six percent for the first time
since 2008 what can be done to help
people
well the most important thing is that
ultimately economic credibility has got
to be re-established because ultimately
when we're seeing those increases in
mortgage rates that's been a direct
result from the conservatives mini
budget that they announced obviously
some time ago now labor said that the
government must come immediately back to
Parliament we've been calling for that
for some time now they need to reverse
that many budget it is ultimately the
cause of these increases
if you say that the mini budget is the
cause and unfunded tax cards why then is
labor adopting a lot of those tax cuts
well actually we're not we've got a
completely different approach when it
comes to fiscal policy compared with the
conservatives we've said that now is not
the time to be for example
yeah because if I've just finished I
mean that they're cutting tax on luxury
goods for tourists they're going ahead
of the corporation tax cuts you know
very very significant in terms of the
amount of money that that would raise
they've got a windfall tax that's full
of holes that isn't backdated in the way
that labor has called for and they're
also of course not releasing the obr's
analysis which has been provided to
government today which we believe
probably would show the negative
economic economic impact of all of these
tax cuts mainly for the wealthiest and
for profit-making companies and the
government's refusing to release that
analysis again if they did release it
that could increase confidence too and
help to get the cost of some of those
mortgages in the future at least down
the government is not acting to Inc
increase economic credibility it's labor
that's the party of economic credibility
and we need that change from the
conservatives as quickly as possible